there are people who like roller
coasters there are people who love
roller coasters and then there are
people like real pendulum
all I need is a little bit of
encouragement to say yes to a crazy idea
my name is will pebble and I built a
roller coaster in my backyard well of
course he did I built a roller coaster
on my backyard because once upon a time
when my son was 10 years old we came
home from vacation and he asked me
wouldn't it be great if we had a roller
coaster in the yard and it took me five
seconds to know for absolute certain
that it would be great to figure out the
first time we wanted to build a roller
coaster there wasn't a whole lot of
information about it okay there were a
couple of videos online that we could
look at the companies that build these
don't really like to share their secrets
and so a lot of what we did we had to
kind of learn as we went I'm trained a
little bit as an engineer I'm trained a
little bit as a carpenter as a builder
I've learned how to weld I know some
stuff but really we had to figure this
out through trial and error and and
while we were doing that we had to make
sure that it all stayed perfectly safe
the whole way the trick to having your
roller coaster turn out the way you hope
it will is you do the math you figure
out what are the laws of physics that
are going to govern this thing and how
do I make those calculations and
understand what the coaster is going to
do before you ever put a shovel in the
ground before you ever bend a piece of
steel in total he's built five coasters
the first one I built in my backyard and
it was made out of PVC in wood about a
hundred and eighty feet of track the
second roller coaster I built in my
front yard because there was already a
roller coaster in the backyard
the third rollercoaster I built for the
Maker Faire in San Francisco because I
wanted to show my roller coaster to more
people than would fit in my yard
the fourth roller coaster I built at a
friend's house because his kid wanted a
roller coaster and we were friends and
this is the fifth roller coaster the
goal boss that I tried to improve on
everything we had done before and I feel
like we've almost gotten ourselves here
the latest is a stomachs whirling
stretch of Steel right out the back door
of his Northern California home a lot of
people would put a swimming pool in the
yard like this just a lot of people most
people would I didn't want that I didn't
think that that would be particularly
engaging I didn't think my kids would
learn a whole lot from that and and look
I have a roller coaster there are no
tickets no lines just strapped into the
homemade cart inch up the hill and then
fly through the turns the way the
coaster works right now is you get in
you go on the chain lift it takes about
30 or 40 seconds to get from the bottom
of the hill to the top of the hill so
it's a pretty slow lift hill what that
does and we could speed it up but we
didn't but what what that does is it
gives you time to kind of review your
choices and think about what you've done
because you look down at the thing and
it doesn't look like any roller coaster
that you've ever ridden before it's like
oh my god who built this thing are you
sure this is safe by the time you get to
the top you're just like you're you just
you know this was a terrible idea and I
have the exact same feeling so you get
that for about 30 seconds and then a
couple of seconds when you just crest
the hill you're like oh okay and then
just like a nice gentle and then you do
this you just like drop off the edge of
the earth into this dive and inside of a
couple of seconds at the bottom of that
first straightaway there you're going 18
miles and
and then you dive into a 70-degree bank
turn and you go 360 450 degrees of 70
degree Bank turn back up into the sky
and then you ride over this trust and
then drop down into that turn over there
which is right next to the wall you go
up the next camel hump which points off
the edge of the wall and on the other
side of that wall is a 15-foot drop into
I don't know what and then you turn off
of that and then you ride into another
Bank and then you roll back to the
station all of that takes less time than
it took me to describe it it takes like
17 seconds from the top of the lift hill
back to the station and it's utterly
horrifying and thrilling and the best
part of all for me it's very very smooth
but it's missing something at least
according to pimples online fans who
follow this coaster building on his
YouTube channel this coaster is awesome
and a lot of people have seen us online
and we get a lot of help and
encouragement from people who watch my
kooky little videos about it one
question that keeps coming up over and
over again is doesn't it go upside down
at any point it doesn't go upside down
yet so I've had a number of people ask
me if we could add some kind of
inversion some way to make the
roller-coaster go upside down here in
the yard I have to try
now Pemble and his coaster collaborator
John Eliot are making the loop-de-loop
dream a reality and yes he insists this
is safe before we built this coaster or
any of the other coasters we started
with a spreadsheet and we did meter by
meter math and physics on how the cart
would behave how the track would behave
what the slopes needed to be what the
bank toll would need to be all of the
things we figured out before we ever
started to build any of it that's the
only way you can have it turn out
predictably yep to absolutely guarantee
that things are safe pema turns to his
friend Todd okay Todd isn't really his
friend he's a crash-test dummy
I know that I weigh 200 pounds and I
want to ride my rollercoaster so we put
our 300-pound crash-test dummy Tod on
the roller coaster and let him ride it a
bunch of times before we ever put a
human being on it so we test everything
[Music]
but an upside down loop is a different
thing entirely the physics of loops is
kind of interesting and presents a
number of opportunities and challenges
one of the main things that you think
about in loops is centripetal
acceleration and that's the force with
which your cart is pushing on the
outside of your loop so how hard is it
pushing against the track with a
perfectly circular loop you need
incredible speed incredible centripetal
acceleration to keep the cart pushing up
when it reaches the top of the loop most
commercial coasters these days use an
upside-down teardrop shaped loop called
a cloth Lloyd loop so the way a clock
lloyd loop looks is when you enter the
loop you have a nice big radius and then
the radius decreases decreases decreases
decreases very tight turn at the top and
then back out of the loop one of the
challenges of our plaque oyd loop will
be that we can't build a really really
big one we're gonna need a relatively
small radius loop the top of our coaster
is 20 feet from the bottom of our
coaster so we basically have 20 feet of
altitude 20 feet of potential energy
that we can use to get in and out of the
loop and when we exit the loop we still
have to finish the whole rest of the
course so we can't use up all our energy
just to get through this loop if we
enter the loop at a certain speed when
we run the math on that what I'm
starting to find is that the G's that
you're gonna pull the force on the cart
and the rider and the track and the
whole system is gonna get pretty freakin
high when you're entering that loop and
by high I mean like 3 4 5 G's really
high is not going to be fun it's not
gonna feel good it might be something
that you'd be proud of having achieved
but it's not going to be
something you would enjoy grinding and
welding Pemble and Eliot have a new
section of track it's not a loop after
all it's a barrel roll which should fit
better into the existing layout and
according to pemba won't subject the
rider too painful g-forces so what we
got here is the very top part of the
barrel roll so what happens is our cart
will enter there's entry down there but
basically the cart enters this part of
the barrel world the rider is pointing
this way and then they spin around this
piece of track and by the time they
finish this top part they've made a 180
degree roll from this to that over the
course of about 18 feet and so we're
feeling very happy about this because
this was the hardest part to build the
materials to build this coaster cost a
little bit less than $10,000 it's the
labor that's gonna get you this roller
coaster took us about three months me
and my friend John worked on it together
and we probably put about 300 hours of
labor into the thing so not a trivial
amount of work I've had a really lucky
and wonderful life I built one of the
biggest web hosting companies in the
world and I sold that and I made a
little bit of money I run a management
consulting company now called goal boss
we teach leadership and teamwork it's
amazing how much of what we learn on the
roller coaster project figures into the
training and consulting that we do the
new section of barrel roll track is
fitted right after the first drop it
really changes how the coaster rides in
this roll the center of gravity of the
rider is way down by your waist which
means that your head whips around and
there's just like a whole lot of energy
it's it's not comfortable it's
borderline not safe utterly scary is the
only person who has ever ridden it and
okay he'll probably be the last it
seemed like an incredibly good idea at
the time now it's really cool to watch
it's really fun to roll the cart over
the thing I've ridden it once and that
was plenty but if you're a crash-test
dummy like Todd
remember him then it's a ton of fun to
ride so my key takeaway from building an
inversion into a roller coaster is if
you don't study engineering and
rollercoaster manufacture you're just
not gonna get it right the first time
and that's okay we're just gonna do it
again I think the best thing to do for
this coaster is to tear it down
completely and rebuild it and design it
from day one with an inversion in mind
my advice to anybody building a backyard
rollercoaster go slow do the math be
careful and know when to not ride it and
don't forget to have a Todd on hand
[Applause]